[Música]
dos años después de que naciera mi hijo
mi esposo y yo decidimos que era tiempo
de nuestro segundo hijo todo solo bien
como esperábamos de pronto me dio la
noticia de que sería papá de nuevo para
mí fue una inmensa alegría y no tardé en
ir al facebook y ponerlo
mi esposa no tardó en regañar me
porque vas y pones todo en el facebook
como adolescente
no me importan los regaños yo estaba muy
feliz
y tuvimos bien hasta la segunda cita con
el ginecólogo
la expresión que hizo el doctor al ver
el ultrasonido la tengo presente en mi
mente hasta ahora
las cosas no iban bien con el embarazo
no se estaba cerrando el feto
nos dio esperanzas que yo sabía que eran
vanas pero mi corazón las quería creer
pues no mi esposa tuvo un aborto
espontáneo porque no se logró el
producto este producto ese término usó
el médico para mi hijo
a mí me paralizó la frialdad con que el
doctor tomo la situación ya con los años
yo entiendo que el doctor
lidia con eso todos los días ya lo
entendí para mí
fue algo traumático no salió el pastel
póngale más harina hágalo de nuevo no
hay problema
yo que soy científico bueno eso creo
logro me como por qué es
tanto que enojado me dijo mira es
multifactorial no se sabe y pasa más
frecuente de lo que tú piensas
y yo me quedé multifactorial quedémonos
quiso decir con eso el doctor
yo no me quedé conforme con esa
respuesta tenía que haber un porqué
bueno
le pregunté está en google
y me dijo que le pasaba entre el 15 y el
10 y el 15 por ciento de las mujeres
es más 50% de los óvulos fecundados
mueren sin que se den cuenta las mujeres
y existen suposiciones de posibles
causas pero pero nada está claro porque
no está claro porque la ciencia ha hecho
cosas muy complicadas saber ese por qué
debe ser una de ellas
yo me quedé con ese dilema dando vueltas
en mi cabeza
y se quedó por un tiempo ahí bueno yo
tengo la costumbre de nunca dejar de
aprender buscar maneras de seguir
aprendiendo un verano tuve la fortuna de
que me diera una beca en un curso en
línea y ese curso hablaba de un
paradigma que tiene que ver con
computación yo lo tomé no sabía bien por
qué pero yo lo tomé
bueno en una de sus referencias encontré
un artículo que hablaba de algo muy
similar a ese dilema que me revoloteaba
en la cabeza
tiene que ver con la evolución y como la
naturaleza lo resuelve perfectamente
y no se entiende porque esto es la vida
inicial según dicen según se cree con un
ancestro común llamado luca
pero cómo fue que la vida pasó de un ser
tan simple a seres tan tremendamente
complejos como los seres humanos como
los animales insectos
pues la evolución se encargó de eso
mediante mutaciones aleatorias la
selección natural y todo lo que nos
cuentan bueno vemos algo en concreto una
de las funciones de la célula es crear
proteínas para eso cuenta con 20
aminoácidos a su disposición
una proteína media contiene alrededor de
unos 300 aminoácidos más o menos si la
evolución se dio por mutaciones
aleatorias cuando las combinaciones
existen para hacer una proteína de ese
tamaño
bueno la respuesta es 20 elevado a la
300 es más grande es el número que el
número de átomos en el universo conocido
es muy improbable que la evolución no
hubiera tropezado con esa configuración
correcta mediante mutaciones aleatorias
se tardarían millones de años entonces
la evolución no es tan aleatoria después
de todo
pero como le hizo
esa bella que yo no sé
bueno si la naturaleza me dice cómo le
hizo yo tal vez pueda tal vez pueda
saber ese por qué de esa cosa que me
estaba revoloteando en la cabeza
tal vez pero bueno alto alto
yo quiero entender algo muy complicado
históricamente como hemos entendido la
naturaleza cómo se hace para saber la
causa de algo bueno para eso el ser
humano ha usado el determinismo esto es
usted puede aislar el objeto del resto
del universo
y analizarlo así
déjeme darle un ejemplo
vamos a ver
y tratar de entender cómo la luna se
mueve alrededor de la tierra se mueve no
se muere se mueve
bueno si yo quiero escribir eso yo puedo
prescindir del sol de los planetas y de
todos los objetos en general del
universo y aún así llegar con un modelo
matemático es lo suficientemente bueno a
eso se le conoce como simplicidad
si podemos conseguir aislar el objeto
podemos encontrar sus causas su
estructura
pero no siempre se puede hallar el
objeto eso es lo multifactorial que se
revela el doctor
entonces como estimamos lo incalculable
bueno ha habido muchas maneras de
estimar qué tan estructurado o aleatorio
es un objeto yo les hablaré de esa de
esa nueva teoría que aprendí en ese
verano se llama la complejidad de
algorítmicas les voy a dar un voy a
contar se basa en la conexión que existe
entre dos conceptos
casualidad y computación a esa conexión
la voy a llamar cálculo
y se puede ver como un programa de
computadora es ese algo aquello me
refería es ese
polvo del arroz con pollo que decía mi
amigo cubano
pero como como como como vamos por
partes computer grandes rasgos es la
habilidad de guardar transformar y
transmitir información piense en su
celular que hace su celular cuando usted
envía un mensaje
computar no es exclusivo del ser humano
es más no es exclusivo ni de los seres
vivos
pero bueno que más hablaste de
información que es la información las
explicaré con un ejemplo verlo de esta
manera la información está relacionado
con lo que nos hace ser nosotros mismos
y no otro ser
es esta diferencia del 1% entre nuestro
adn y el de un chimpancé que nos hace
ser nosotros
como los científicos de esas áreas dicen
es esa pequeña diferencia que hace la
diferencia
bueno la buena noticia es que se puede
medir a finales de los años 40 causaron
tenía la encomienda de medir cuánta
información se puede pasar por un cable
telefónico
y propuso su teoría de la información
que es un formalismo construido
automáticamente mide la información en
bits
un beats es la medida de la distinción
entre dos posibilidades 0 1 cierto falso
arriba abajo pero pero eso ya nos lo usó
el concepto de entropía que ya se
conocía desde la física
eso sirve para estimar lo aleatorio de
un objeto también
la pregunta es
porque es necesario un nuevo enfoque
voy a hacer una pausa y recapitular lo
que quiero
yo quiero saber si un objeto es
aleatorio y si lo es que tanto
para eso yo deseo tener una propiedad de
un objeto que se pueda cuantificar
la propiedad hecha no lo hace que me la
quitan aleatorio es el objeto la
entropía de chan hol lo hace pero algo
más fundamental que no tenga
dificultades con lidiar con
distribuciones de probabilidad porque es
ocultan la complejidad lo notorio que
subyace en ese objeto
la entropía de chano no lo hace de hecho
usa estas distribuciones de
probabilidades que si no las conoce las
asume como uniformes
bueno esta teoría que les estoy contando
empezó a desarrollarse por gente como
colmo coro satin y recientemente por el
doctor senil de la energía de doctor
esta nueva teoría se basa en tres
conceptos fundamentales el primero trata
de capturar la imposibilidad de predecir
un objeto aleatorio
el segundo
trate de capturar el hecho de que no se
puede describir un objeto aleatorio de
manera simple o corta y el tercero que
nos diga que un objeto la torre no tiene
particularmente especial
nada
bueno en el corazón de esta teoría se
encuentra un ingrediente muy esencial la
máquina universal de turing
tal vez usted haya visto en nekrif quien
ya dije
corey buenísima
el personaje de esa película es alan
turing el que diseñó a esa máquina que
la propuso la máquina universidad de
turín es un objeto matemático que
representa de manera abstracta a una
computadora
uno alimenta la máquina de turing
leer a un programa y la máquina de
asturias lo realiza y te da un resultado
pero puede ser que ese programa no
termine nunca lo que se conoce como el
teorema de parada
ahora
pongamos un poquito de matemáticas no
muchas poquitas la complejidad de
algorítmica o de colmo foro se designa
con la letra k usa las mismas unidades
de bits que usa la entropía de shannon
es la longitud del programa más corto
que corriendo en la máquina de turing
genera en la secuencia x a la que le
asociamos el objeto
esto es usted traiga algo interesante de
la naturaleza represente lo con esta
secuencia
corre un programa en la máquina
[Música]
marca me gusta de touring que genera esa
secuencia y la más corta es es la caja
pero casi incalculable chin
no se puede hacer buenas diferentes
maneras de editar con eso para medirse
acá el doctor senil
tiene es pionero en una metodología y de
ahí voy a tomar el método de lector emma
de codificación que en pocas palabras es
un formalismo que no calcula que lo
aproxima usando lo que se conoce como
problema de algorítmica designada con la
letra m la propiedad algorítmica nos
dará la probabilidad de que un código
programa sea generado al lateralmente y
que nos den esa cadena
esta secuencia x que andamos buscando
si el objeto es simple habrá muchos
programas que lo generen
si por el contrario es aleatorio habrá
pocos programas y el programa será tan
grande como la misma secuencia
ayayay se oye bonito muchas cosas a ver
bueno voy a tratar de explicar con este
ejemplo que estoy seguro que lo van a
entender
tal vez haya oído hablar de la secuencia
de fibonacci bueno la secuencia empieza
con los números 0 y 1
el siguiente número me lo va a dar la
suma de los dos números anteriores 0 11
entonces el siguiente número me lo va a
dar la suma de 1 1 2 el siguiente número
para dar la suma de 2 + 1 3 y así
sucesivamente imagínese que usted no
sabe cómo se generó esta secuencia usted
no lo ignora no sé no sé
pero resulta que esos números que están
apareciendo como los números de casos
contagiados en una epidemia no se cual
una epidemia
si usted quiere encontrar si eso es lo
que me está diciendo la naturaleza que
yo lo traje en esa que tiene una
estructura algo
si usted lo mide con un antro pero ya no
va a encontrar que tiene que si esa
secuencia es totalmente aleatoria y
entre más números tenga más
sin embargo por otro lado con la
complicada rítmica
y usted va a medir correctamente que esa
secuencia está dada por algo tiene
estructura
así de poderoso es esta es esa nueva
teoría bueno esa es la sabiduría que
tiene es la evolución y que yo no sé he
estado probando con estas teorías que
les acabo de presentar después de todo
recuerde que le dije que la evolución
nuestra mala toria y la evolución se ve
sesgada por el entorno ese sesgo se
asocia con una evolución algorítmica
como lo dice el doctor senil y ha dado
buenos resultados
ha predicho cosas que pasan en la
evolución
pero usas objetos pequeños esto es no
usado
escuchas grandes tan grandes como el adn
todavía falta mucho por eso pero los
problemas modernos
están requiriendo soluciones monedas
bueno para concluir aún falta mucho
camino no sé si me alcance tiempo a mí
no sé si mi vida alcance mis pocas
habilidades científicas me den para
comprender eso que tanto me revolotea en
la cabeza por lo pronto yo estoy
trabajando duro y disfrutando mucho su
misión como dijo una hermosa nena que va
a cumplir dos años
y ha traído mucha felicidad a mi vida
muchas gracias
[Música]